you know what's crazy is tyson can still
make you [ __ ] your pants in the ring too
yeah roy jones took three hits and was
like i want none of that
yeah yeah he was grabbing his side yeah
in the
post fight interviews and mike's like we
have to run it back
we have to run it back and roy's like um
yeah i'm gonna talk to my family
it looked like roy just finished hot
ones that's what he looks like
so he's still sweating and mike tyson's
just like standing there like yeah it
was pretty fun
yeah have you ever seen cliffs of roy in
his prime
no oh my god man oh my god
so was he like oh a real technical
fighter
or was he because it kind of dude he was
just [ __ ]
hey no bro he was the master of the no
look jab
that guy oh bro you need to watch a
highlight reel of roy jones
okay roy jones could be not looking at
you that was like his thing like he
would he'd step
off from you and start dancing and then
you'd try to advance and just
bow he'd just laser you like you think
he's completely
untouchable he's got this great clip i
forgot who he's fighting where
um he's kind of staring at this dude in
the mirror
he [ __ ] opens up his guard and he
pops his mouthpiece out
like on his tongue like he's like and
then you see the dude in slow-mo
loading up and roy jones in slo-mo gets
his mouthpiece back in
and whaps him before the guy can even
like
get off he had a [ __ ] insane speed
man should i try and find it
here i'll find the best one he's also
got
he also he also made music and uh
really yeah he's got bruh
he's got some some of the best fight
music
in history i think it's this one
hold on can you send it yeah sorry i
can't find it
just searching for things on the podcast
never really works out does it
okay you cannot um
you're definitely gonna have to mute
this okay that's fine this this song
right that that's the thing that was
that upset me the most
then you know setting me feel like who's
roy jones man
this guy stinks it's like dude you don't
even know who you're looking at
is it right here yeah okay hold on just
mute that audio oh it's nine minutes
where's the
i mean you can uh here oh this is just
like a general
here i'll scrub through and find the cut
i'm thinking of i mean there's just
they're all great
yeah i mean the fight was a little it
wasn't sad but it was like
why are why is this happening you know
yeah it just kind of seemed like
they talked so much about like legacy
and about
like how you know they've dreamed about
this fight for so long and all this
stuff and
and they're fighting and it's just like
oh man this is clearly just for money
right is that am i am i bad for thinking
that like it's like if you're talking
about legacy and all this stuff just let
let the legacy exist then you know
i see what you're saying mike looked
pretty
goddamn good he looked you know he did
look good and it also i guess like
he lost 100 pounds he also looked like
he still
had it in him to
um oh it was it right here right here
427 okay okay
that guy tries to touch him with the
left and he gets
two see it yeah i see it
oh oh oh oh oh that you got to mute
that's fine
all right here it comes wait for it wait
for it
he tried to touch him with the left and
he gets two
look look he's not even looking at it
he's dancing
he was jacked dude bro he he was
one of the fastest ever look at that
but he's still still he's like
hit me come on come on come on come on
come on come on
haunting him oh my god
oh look at that oh reading the play
reading the play
you ain't [ __ ] you ain't [ __ ]
wow yeah
um no i honestly m ty first of all
tyson did that fight high which is
amazing that's wild
putting on for stoners worldwide yeah
for jacob sartorius
yes big reefer dude he's a big reefer
did you see that on tick-tock nah is it
him just getting blowed
he just did a couple tick tocks in a row
about smoking weed and like what it
feels like it was like memes right like
what would i feel like when i smoke weed
not worried about it one of them he made
a song
it's actually kind of it's actually kind
of funny pull it up yeah hold on i'll
pull it up real quick
but he did a couple take talks about
smoking weed in a row and then it kind
of
kind of became a meme on tick tock for a
sec only
i just want to finish my thought and say
the fact that tyson
no the fact that tyson seemed like he
had killer instinct while high
[Music]
it just makes me wonder what he could do
sober yeah
i think he needs to be high so the the
real mike tyson didn't come out in that
fight
you know what i mean yeah you know i
feel that if he was sober and roy
touched him he said i have to kill him
now yeah yeah and he would
he would have murdered roy i think he
would have punched through roy's body
through the ring to the center of the
earth and i think
yeah i think he would have just blew up
the earth just oh
yeah and just yeah one clean hole
through the void
cartoon like no gus or anything
you could stare down that hole for miles
and miles and he's just
drilling to the center of the earth
all right this is what this is what mike
felt like before the fight what's up
everybody so
the other night got high as [ __ ] right
and i wrote a song about the two loves
of my life
here it is it's like youtube and
barbecue chips
when i get high i just be like so i
wrote
two songs
why is he tweaking back and forth so
much what else is he doing
because yeah well he doesn't say what he
was high on
uh i know it has the leaf emoji but that
could be
you know like there's different types of
leafs you know bro i want i want a tick
tocker
to or like some young influencer to just
get on pcp and be unapologetic about it
yeah casual yeah you know where's pcp
talk yeah if i want like on that i want
like bryce hall to just start doing pcp
yo what up this is a piece lift
um just did like a half a gram and i'm
gonna
dead lift seven thousand pounds
lifts a car that's a crazy thing about
tick tock is that those communities
actually exist
oh yeah i was scrolling down my page and
one of them one of them was like
um when you just did your uh no it was
like when you pop an adderall at 4 am to
combat the coke come down
all the comments were like bro i'm there
right now
i'm feeling this right now i just popped
an addie i was like i prefer xanax
like how are you guys are you not
worried about like
potential employers seeing this ah nah
nah it's not even in the question man
yeah
well dude it's a pandemic what employer
where are you gonna go work right now
that's a good point
amazon yeah you hired like 400 000
people over the last four months or
something like that
someone told me a grim conspiracy where
they thought amazon was just
paying the pandemic like they're just
trying to pay their way
to shutdowns so people their only
employment option would be them
and they could just [ __ ] destroy the
market
and they could that's a great theory
yeah and they could good conspiracy
theory
and and uh uh that
you know then that made me feel oh my
god
how just like [ __ ] awful would that
be if we found out in 20 years that
they just paid for shutdowns to murder
small business
so that the only option in town ah
yeah yeah so what are you saying they're
like lobbying
government i mean i don't know how that
actually would work yeah
yeah yeah but damn that's that's a
fun theory it's a fun conversation there
isn't super fun
yeah i love that i love it makes me feel
super good and it's a fun
theory i mean there are people right now
in in
certain states where you know they're
they don't abide by any of this [ __ ]
you know this coven's not real there
yeah so
yeah um you saw beverly hills is voting
against the [ __ ]
restaurant ban really yeah the rich
people are like no
we will eat outside we need we i need
that kobe beef
[Laughter]
i will eat outside
i will eat outside it's also like 30
degrees here now
yeah what the [ __ ] some days it's
messed up bro
you